Mayor: As mayor of...the universe,
I award C. C. Cuckooclocks as the biggest lover of Christmas in all the galaxies.
Your love of this holiday is unrivaled by...anyone.
CC: Thank you all so much for this award! I'm very flattered by it.
It is so wonderful to know that no one in the entire solar system or anywhere else loves Christmas as much as I.
[Explosions in the distance]
What was that?
Mayor: Well, it sounds like the light barrier being broken.
[Explosion in the distance]
And the speed of time being warped.
[Explosions in the distance]
And every conceivable ozone layer being shattered.
[Space Ship flying and Explosions in the distance]
NC: CHRIIIIISTMAAAAAAAAAAS!
[Clears Throat]
I win.
When life gives you lemons, you say,
"Fuck lemons, where's my Christmas?".
It's the greatest time of the year, and we're once again gonna celebrate all the merriment it has to offer.
The snow, the hot chocolate,
whatever the hell I'm looking at here,
Christmas has everything!
And as part of celebrating the holidays, we also have to look at the weirdest parts of it.
No, not Patrick Stewart wearing a singing elf hat.
You can watch that later.
I'm of course talking about Inspector Gadget Saves Christmas!
It's a weird list of people
who have saved Christmas, isn't it?
Ernest,
the Berenstain Bears,
the Glo Friends,
Elmo,
Mater from Cars,
Diego,
the Bratz Babyz,
escaped mental ward patients,
Felix the Cat.
It kinda feels like ANYONE can save Christmas. It's not particularly hard.
So why not throw Inspector Gadget into the mix?
Based on the hit kids' show about a bumbling inspector and his ignored prodigy of a niece,
this special aired in December of 1992,
just 6 years before its cinematic follow-up, still awaiting an apology tour.
"No! I gotta get outta here!"
[Teeth Clanking]
That man was nominated for an Oscar.
The great thing about this special is it's pretty much EXACTLY what you think it's gonna be.
The first few images that pop in your head when you hear this title is 100% what it consists of.
It's ridiculous in the ways only Inspector Gadget can provide!
So let's Go-Go-Gadget Dollar Store Cash-In!
This is Inspector Gadget Saves Christmas!
We start off outside the incredibly well-advertised Santa's Workshop.
Y'know, you're sending mixed signals with the wooden sign, yet electric lettering.
Why don't you just put this on there while you're at it?
Santa wakes up his workers with his synthesized trumpet-playing,
a man of many random talents,
and he wakes them up again by singing, because apparently the trumpet did nothing.
"Rise and shine, elves! Ho ho ho ho!"
♪ Rise and shine he says ♪
♪ From our elfin' beds ♪
Did they just say their effin' beds?!
♪ Rise and shine he says ♪
♪ From our elfin' beds ♪
Guys, kids are watching!
♪...our green outfits, and cap our elfin' heads ♪
OK, the swear jar's over there!
♪ Jingle bells, elfin' bells ♪
Christ, does your music need a parental warning?!
The lyrics get even more grim the further you listen to 'em.
♪ Die another day ♪
♪ For our milk and pay ♪
♪ Play is work, and work is play ♪
Maaaan, Santa runs a pretty unforgiving setup.
Imagine these words being spoken instead of sung.
Yeah, die another day!
Making toys for Santa isn't work, it's play!
Play is work, work is play.
[Thunderous Noises]
So after we realize Santa shanghaied the Keebler elves through some sort of illegal cloning ring,
our main villain, Dr. Claw, enters the picture.
Yes, this is really happening!
Dr. Claw is dressing up like Santa!
I am not prepared for this kind of silly!
Maybe if I watch this:
OK, OK, let's try it again.
"I, Dr. Cla-"
Nope, not working!
[Laughs hysterically]
I have...
so many questions!
First of all: Wow! Who know Dr. Claw was so short?
I guess sitting down so much just gives you the shin-legs of Hank Hill's father!
Second: His arms seem to have gotten pretty scrawny don't you think?
Does he eat carbs?
Third: What exactly is his scheme, again?
"I, Dr. Claw, will ruin Christmas myself, and the world will blame Santa Claus!"
That's a weird plan, buddy.
What do you care if you ruin Christmas? Or even if Santa gets blamed?
You focus used to be robberies, terrorism, obtaining power.
What does making Santa look lazy accomplish?
"Santa's name will be slush! His reputation will be ruined!"
[evil laughter]
And I will have the honor of...
having done that!
No wonder you kept losing to an 8-year-old; your criminal plans center around what 8-year-olds care about!
You're making this guy look credible now!
"Wha...how dare you!"
So Dr. Claw uses his mind-controlling hats on the elves,
because this is our reality for the next half-hour,
and operates a hook crane to lift Santa.
"Get me down!"
Jack Skellington, I told you I'm done with this shit!
"Only one person can stop me now.
And my MAD agents will stop him first!"
As soon as I figure out how to stop the snow from looking like streams of urine!
Seriously, are a bunch of snowmen taking a piss up there?
Thus, we see Inspector Gadget at his house,
as MAD agents try to get him.
Look at this, they couldn't even get the original Inspector Gadget theme song.
Female Singer: ♪ Inspector Gadget ♪
(Jazz/Pop Style Music Playing)
Male Singer: ♪ Inspector Gadget ♪
Oh, c'mon, the theme song was like half the show!
What's this shit they're playing?!
♪ Inspector Gadget ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh-oh ♪
♪ We're clearly making this up ♪
♪ As we goOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoO ♪
They of course fail to stop him,
most likely because of his offscreen Portal gun,
How'd he...what?
as Inspector Gadget is given his next assignment from the Chief, once again undercover.
"But where's the real Santa?"
"He could be in trouble!
Here, your assignment will explain."
Boy, the Chief is sounding like Clint Eastwood
after a million Marlboros.
"I know! Now get off the phone!"
(Voice: NC) "Do you feel jolly, punk?"
"Suspicious activity at North Pole. Suggests MAD plot by Dr. Claw against the real Santa Claus."
Y'know, the thought occurs to me that we're rather Claw-centric.
Have we ever thought about going after ISIS?
Drug lords?
The people who make the Madea movies?
"I'll get to the bottom of this!"
(Voice: NC) "Y'know, this has happened so much,
it's actually starting to feel good."
So Gadget, being the caring uncle that he is,
of course brings his niece Penny along, who
"With Santa Claus and his elves! Ha ha!
Tough break, huh, Brain?"
is clearly voiced by a different actress.
Oh, c'mon, how could you replace Cree Summer?
She's like a voice acting giant!
She was perfect for Penny Gadget!
HOW DARE THEY GET A LITTLE KID TO VOICE A LITTLE KID?!
What's wrong with you?
Well, maybe her acting's so good, it's a fitting replacement.
"This must be where Dr. Claw hid Santa's real toys!"
OK, well, maybe she's popular from the other things she's been in, like:
Linnea Quigley's Horror Workout-
I have no idea why they chose this person.
"Oh, look, Uncle Gadget! Santa's Village! It's a Christmas dream come true!"
If only we could fix the reception!
Gadget falls in the snow, but he quickly gets out with a bit of comedy.
"If you get my drift!"
(Both Penny and Brain Laugh)
(NC Laughs)
NC as Penny: I invented the laser watch. This humor's beneath me.
So we saw how easily Dr. Claw snuck in. I wonder if they beefed up security at all-
DO THEY EVEN LOCK THEIR DOORS?!
Aren't you even afraid those elves might be kidnapped by Willy Wonka when you're not looking?
Gadget, of course, goes to greet who he thinks is Santa.
Santa Claws: "Ah, Gadget! You're always welcome at the North Pole!"
NC (vo): (as Gadget) Why, Santa, you're sounding charmingly Satanic today!
Gadget: "My chief has the silly idea that the notorious Dr. Claw has infiltrated the North Pole!"
Dr. Claw: "Ho ho ho!"
OK, I'm just calling it right here.
I think Dr. Claw should be our new Santa!
Dr. Santa Claw!
Hearing him say "Ho ho ho!" is my everything!
Christmas would be amazing if he was Santa!
Just imagine him greeting kids at the mall!
Girl: I want a dolly, and a gumball, and a tea set-
Dr. Santa Claw: What you need is a trip to my fire pit!
Girl: WHAAAAAAAA!
Dr. Santa Claw: What do you want?
Boy: I want a puppy!
Santa Claw: Puppies suck. Get a kitten!
Boy: I hate kittens! Kittens are all stupid and boring!
Santa Claw: How dare you!
Roger: Dr. Claw?
Dr. Santa Claw: What's up?
Roger: I can't help but notice all the children you're torturing in horrific ways?
Santa Claw: It's not my fault discipline is dead!
Roger: Dr. Claw, just exactly what are you a doctor of?
Dr. Santa Claw: Pediatrics.
Roger: I have a hard time believing that, sir.
Dr. Santa Claw: I have a hard time believing your face!
Roger: Now that is not called for!
Dr. Santa Claw: Oh, piss off, ya pansy!
Oh, when will they realize any one of these kids could invent a computer-book and ruin all our schemes?
I'm just ahead of my time.
[Commercial Break]
[Commercial Break Finish]
So Penny starts to put together that something might be up.
"Hi! I'll bet you have some great Santa stories, Mr. Elf!"
[Ghost Screeching Sound Effect]
Interesting sound effect choice.
Did he have flashbacks when he was on the ship from Alien?
[Ghost Screeching Sound Effect]
[Xenomorph Cries in Background]
[Heart Beating]
"Nice talkin' to ya!
There's something weird going on here, Brain."
NC (as Penny): "Yeah, there's something weird about these enchanted elves, magical talking dog."
So of course Penny, once again, has to save the day while Gadget just makes things worse.
God, I wish she got the credit she deserves.
I mean, I know it's good to be humble and everything, but I think her picture would be placed above J. Edgar Hoover's by this point.
And don't you think Brain would get a little pissed off seeing how he's always the one who has to save Gadget while she calmly snoops around?
Why does he always get the short end of the stick?
"Come in, Brain! You follow Uncle Gadget, I'm gonna find out what's going on."
"What next?!"
So Gadget inspects the factory as well as the toys.
Or rather, sings about it.
♪ On the first day's inspection, good Santa showed to me ♪
♪ A mountain bike with Gadget training wheels ♪
Do his vocal cords have one bar? What's up with the audio?
How the hell did his voice go from this:
"Go-Go-Gadget Magnifying Glass!"
to:
♪ On the first day's inspection,
good Santa showed to me ♪
For crying out loud, I think he literally phoned this in!
Was he just sitting at his home like:
"I don't wanna come down to the studio. I'm too busy seeing who played a worse me."
"I'll just record it in my garage. I hear the acoustics there are amazing."
"Would you believe semi-amazing?"
♪ On the fifth day's inspection,
good Santa showed to me ♪
NC: ♪ A song that goes on too long because we need some filler and it's public domain so we don't have to pay for it ♪
Gadget: ♪ And a jet-propelled Inspector Gadget! ♪
Gadget is tossed into the same holding cell as Santa as-
Wait a minute.
I know that's where Santa's being held. It's like a special dungeon so he can't get out and everything, but...
Why does Santa have one of those in the first place?
This workshop is getting creepier and creepier. Maybe Dr. Claw is more of a hero than we gave him credit for!
"Go-Go-Gadget Interrogation Device!"
Yeah, Inspector Gadget might have the right idea this time!
"Was it Dr. Claw? Talk!"
(Santa Giggling)
OK, that's a little weird.
"Yes, Dr. Claw!"
"Ha! You expect me to believe that?"
Why do I get the feeling this is gonna be a sequel to the movie "Tickled"?
Is there a Santa getting tickled fetish?
Don't tell me if there is!
"So far, you've failed to shake like a bowl full of jelly-"
OK, this special needs an R-rating, because I swear he said "shit like a bowl full of jelly"!
"You've failed to shake like a bowl full of jelly-"
NC as Gadget: Those Metamucil cookies I left out every year always did the trick!
"Your eyes don't twinkle, your dimples aren't merry, and this ratty, fake beard wouldn't fool anyone!"
Well, this is horrific.
Is this what you were expecting, kids? Watching your childhood icon get the shit beat out of him by law enforcement?
♪ Fa la la la la, la la la la ♪
Gadget's really not doing much saving Christmas, is he?
He's more...Guantanamo-ing Christmas.
Gangster from Home Alone 2:
"Merry Christmas, you filthy animal!"
Meanwhile, Penny has to figure out what's going on with as little conviction as possible.
"He's in a jail cell? That's bad."
Goddammit, kid!
"He found the real Santa Claus? That's good!"
Ugh, you're turning one of the greatest child heroes into a LeapFrog preschool game!
Can you spot what's good and bad?
"That's good.
That's bad.
That's good.
That's bad."
"Uncle Gadget put a dog collar on Santa?"
OK, this is getting a little weird for me!
The tickling in the dungeon and the effin' elves were one thing, but THIS IS A KIDS SHOW!
Inspector Gadget escapes and helps Claw load up his sleigh.
"Here you go."
Uh, I'm sorry, are you sure Gadget's not the villain here?
"But haven't you forgotten Dunderhead, Blitzkrieg, and the other reindeer?"
"I'll take care of everything myself."
Y'know, I should really fire my strategist if this is the person I've been losing to all these years!
But Brain and Penny try to get the elves back to their normal selves,
especially after they master teleportation.
OK, is Scotty just traveling back in time and randomly beaming people?
But they find the control and return them to their usual swearing selves.
♪ Jingle bells, elfin' bells ♪
You are all getting soap for dinner!
But Claw isn't done yet.
Dr. Claw: Too little, Too late Gadget.
NC: Oh come on, even his sleigh is cooler.
WHY CAN'T HE BE SANTA?!
If Tim Allen gets 3 movies, WHY CAN'T HE?!
Dr. Santa Claws: When I deliver these defective toys, you can't stop me from ruining Christmas.
Wow, for the first time ever MAD Cat, I actually listened to what I said out loud.
I'm a buffoon.
Santa Claus: Ho! Ho! Ho! Go Go Santa Reindeer!
(Voice: NC) Ha Ha! I just quoted a man who tortured me for hours.
Insanity: 1, My Mental Health: 0
(Voice: Normal) I'll Show em all!
NC: The Reindeer's antlers somehow dig through a iceberg of solid mass.
Steroid Oats!
And sink Dr. Claw's Plan into the Ocean.
Dr. Claw: I'll get you!!
NC: Look at the blank stares on those elfs..
They've seen things.
Things which they can never explain nor wish to understand.
Just move on.
Never look back.
Cheif: I don't know how you did this.
NC: Whah!
NC: Where the hell did he come from?
Chief: But you saved Christmas for the children of the world.
"No time for that Chief, Christmas awaits."
NC as Chief: But I've been waiting for hours somehow in the sky, it's like the Bermuda Triangle of air-pockets.
NC: So Santa, gets his Sleigh going and even invites Gadget to come along with him.
♪ Jingle Bells, Jingle Bells, Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh what fun it was to ride in ♪
♪ Santa's Open Sleigh ♪
NC (as Santa): Alright, we're high enough. Let's toss him.
Gadget: Waaaaaaaaaa!
Don't Mess with the Clause!
NC: So that was "Inspector Gadget Saves Christmas".
It's pretty much exactly what you'd except from it.
It's Silly, Ridiculous and doesn't make a lick of sense.
But, that's part of what you expect when you watch Inspector Gadget.
If you hear the title "Inspector Gadget Saves Christmas" and you have ANY interest in it what so ever.
It's proudly going to give what you're looking for.
Gadget acting like a dummy, Dr. Claw trying to take over the North Pole, Brain getting hurt in the process.
The only thing that always sucks like I said before is Penny always getting the Shaft.
I hate that, she's the one doing all the hard work. She should get the credit.
It's not fair I tell you. It's NOT FAIR!
Can we just ONE day see Penny get exactly what she deserves?
[Static Noise]
NC: What is that?
???: Greetings, people of the world.
For the years, you've been under the assumption that my uncle, "Inspector Gadget" was a respected detective for the Metro City Police Force.
This was all just a cunning ruse.
Penny: Did you really think such a bumbling Dick
with the voice of Don Adams
could accomplish super impossible feats
and STILL be Human?
For GOD's Sake, He has a Fucking Helicopter in his head!
and yet Nobody questions where the hell his brain is.
I created the "Gadget 9000" prototype, and you dumbasses fell for it.
And now that I have created artificial life, I shall unleash it on an unsuspecting world!
Your tanks and stealth bombers are no match for the hellfire I'm about to unleash!
[Static Noise]
Do you know how difficult it was to constantly be in the shadows as that incompetent shit got all the credit?
I compressed the entire internet into my textbook,
taught a canine how to simulate human speech,
and created the Apple watch before Steve Jobs was out of his mother's basement!
Give me another ten years, I would've created a fucking Matrix,
complete with a Keanu Reeves that can actually act!
[Static Noise]
You thought the real enemy was MAD,
but they were Merely A Distraction.
As long as Gadget and Claw fought,
the police were always occupied.
For, you see, I was foiling MAD's plans
so that when the time came,
I could seize control of your governments, your thermonuclear warheads, your lives!
I am PENNY, Mother of Gadgets, Breaker of Brains!
I will take back the honor that was stolen from me and destroy those that stand in my way!
Isn't that right, Uncle Gadget?
Gadget: Wowzers.
Penny: Penny for your thoughts, bitches?
Cree Summer: Does that work?
NC: Yeah but, you were supposed to say.
"Ooh, I don't like that, Uncle Gadget."
Cree as Penny: Yeah, not anymore.
NC: Okay...
[Ending Music]
Penny: "That's bad."
Doug: Hey guys, Doug Walker doing the Charity Shoutout.
This week, we are doing the Midwest Foodbank.
This Charity works to stop hunger and poverty by gathering and distributing food donations to over 9 hundred non-profit local organizations and disaster sites.
Based on the data from Charity Navigator, the firm has achieved the highest rating for fiscal responsibility and excellence for 6 consecutive years.
For fiscal 2014 of the 63.221 million dollars raised,
99.30% went directly towards delivering it's services and only 0.50% went towards administrative expenses.
That's Amazing.
If you look at their site or their YouTube page, you can see for yourself all the great work that they do.
They work so hard in making sure that people this holiday season don't go hungry.
There's so many people that need food in the world and these are the people that make it possible that they don't go to bed starving.
It's a wonderful organization and defiantly deserves your attention.
This Christmas, when so many people are in a charitable mood, defiantly keep this one in mind.
Open your hearts, and take a look.